robert spencer on in november 2021 cair
the council on american islamic
relations welcomed a vote by virginia's
washington county board of supervisors
to remove some confederate monuments why
because these people were slave owners
and we all know
how against slavery islam is um except
they're not are they robert
uh that's the ridiculous thing about
this uh the koran takes slavery for
granted slavery is still practiced
widely in north africa and other areas
of the islamic world despite the fact
that it's officially illegal because the
people who practice it they uh
simply ignore the secular law and they
believe that islamic law allows for it
so
in the first place care is counting on
you not knowing that
in the second place they're trying to
sow division in american society because
of course the statues of the
confederates were uh built in the first
place not because people were in favor
of slavery but because they wanted to
recognize that there were
good people noble people who fought for
the confederacy now nobody can
understand that nowadays because they
would say oh that means that you must
love slavery and you're racist and so on
in earlier ages people had a more wide
expensive understanding of the
complexity of human nature and the fact
that uh when some moral principles like
slavery were not entirely clear some
people came out on the wrong side but
that didn't mean that they were 100 evil
anyway
care is trying to stir up division in
american society by pitting americans
against americans and making us
ashamed of our history and our heritage
and so on and that's why they speak out
against these statues but it's yet
another example of their hypocrisy
in the fact that islam is the only
religion that actually does allow
slavery and it was in england and
america only that the abolitionist
movement arose